hey everyone my name is iran and i'm
going to be presenting the talk about
pcbs and incense compression from a
cryptographic lens
this was a joint work together with ron
rothburn from the technion so let's
begin by talking about what the
cryptographic lens means
now it is often the case in cryptography
that cryptographers assume that the
adversary that they're working against
is computationally bounded that means
that unlike in the information theoretic
setting where the adversary can do
anything
here the adversary can only run in some
bounded time
using this assumption cryptographers
bypass impossibility results building
objects that were impossible in the
classical information theoretic setting
in this work we're going to continue
this trend and we're going to bypass
impossibility results and build
computational analogs of succinct pcps
and instance compression and we do so by
assuming that the adversary is
computationally bounded just like in the
cryptographic cryptographic
lens setting
in this talk we're going to have three
parts the first is going to be about
pcps we're going to discuss
the limitations around pcps and how we
bypass them second of all we're going to
discuss instance compression how we
bypass the impossibility results using a
cryptographic analog and lastly we're
going to discuss the technical overview
of how we achieve our results
so let's begin pcp's a cryptographic
perspective
so pcps or probabilistically checkable
proofs are a proof system for language l
and p which have the following setting
we have a lazy verifier who has an
instance x
and the verifier wants to know whether x
belongs in the language l or not
so what the verifier does is he contacts
a prover denoted by this nerd emoji and
the prover has both the instance x and
claims to have a witness w for the fact
that x belongs in a language l
approver computes a pcp proof
uh which he then grants the verifier
oracle access to and this proof is very
long and the verifier is very lazy so
instead of reading the entire proof
the verifier only queries pi at a few
indices i1 to iq
and using the results of its queries it
decides whether to accept or reject
so the requirements for pcps are the
following
first of all we have completeness
which states that if x belongs in the
language l
then when interacting with the honest
prover there exists a proof the proof
written by disprover which makes the
verifier accept
the second requirement the soundness
which is the um complementary
requirement
which states that if if x doesn't belong
to l
then one interacting with a malicious
prover denoted by this devil emoji but
not just any malicious proverb this
prover can be almighty all-knowing
all-powerful it can compute whatever it
wants
um then for whichever proof this
terrible prover writes pi star
the verifier rejects with constant with
non-negligible probability
so when we learn about pcps we all hear
that pcps have polynomial overhead
so what you might assume this means that
is that the length of the proof pi is
polynomial in the length of the witness
w but that's not actually the case
because for all known pcp constructions
length of the proof is polynomial both
in the length of the witness but also in
the length of the instance which can be
much much longer
and here's the running example you
should be thinking of um for the
language sat you can have
instances which are very long compared
to their witnesses so the end of the
assignment is poly logarithmic in the
length of the
formula thus you have very short
witnesses but very long instances and
ideally we'd like there to be succinct
pcbs for sat and which the length of the
proof is polynomial in the length of the
witness instead of the much much longer
instance
so the existence of such pcps was an
open question until 2011
um in which for now and xanthanum
show that these succinct pcps for sat
simply cannot exist
unless the polynomial hierarchy
collapses
um so it seems that we're an impasse we
simply cannot build these pcps under
standard computational assumptions but
perhaps we can build something that is
very close to being ssync pcp and here
the cryptographic perspective comes into
play
kaleiros defined back in 2009 in a
cryptographic analog of a pcp called a
pca or a probabilistically checkable
argument which is basically going to be
a computationally sound pcp
what this means is
we have the same setting of a language
ln np a lazy verifier who wants to know
whether x belongs in the language l and
a prover who claims to have a witness w
for that fact and now we also have a
common random string or a crs for short
which is basically a random string known
to both parties sampled before the
protocol begins
so what the prover does is he writes a
proof by a pca proof based on the
input instance the witness and the crs
and he grants the verifier oracle access
to the spoof pi
the verifier then chooses indices i1 to
iq and reads pi at these specific
indices
and chooses whether to accept or reject
accordingly
the requirements for pca are similar to
what we had before first of all we have
completeness which states that fx
belongs in the language l
then for every choice of crs there
exists a proof written by this honest
prover which makes the verifier accept
and second of all the slightly different
computational soundness requirement
states that if x does not belong to the
language l then when interacting with a
bounded uh malicious prover now this
prover doesn't have scary dynamic votes
meaning that it's computationally
bounded
with high probability over the choice of
the crs
and for whichever proof pi star this
computationally bound the approval
rights the verifier rejects with high
probability
so the interesting question now is
whether there exists succinct pcas for
sat we saw that sync pcps cannot exist
so maybe pcas might exist and actually
caller has answered this question back
in 2009 the positive
um they said assuming crypto such
succinct pcas for set do exist
but they have two major caveats um the
first is that this pca construction is
designated verifier meaning
that only the specific verifier
which
generated the crs and therefore has some
kind of trapdoor secret trapdoor to the
crs can verify the proof and no one else
can verify the proof and this is in
contrast to pcps in which everyone can
verify pcb proof
and the second caveat is the fact that
their pca construction has super
constant query complexity um it's
actually polyalgorithmic which isn't bad
but it's not quite as good as pcps in
which we have constant query complexity
which is the best we could hope for
and in this work actually we get rid of
both of these caveats
and we do so in theorem one
and theorem one states the following
assume subexponential lwe a standard
cryptographic assumption
then for every bonded depth and p
relation there exists publicly
verifiable constant query succinct pcas
so in other words we build pcas for a
very large subset of np relations while
eliminating both of these caveats uh
first of all our pca construction is
publicly verifiable meaning that
everyone can verify the construction
not just a specific verifier with a
trapdoor
and second of all it has constant query
complexity just like with pcps
and also it is succinct just like we
wanted before so the proofs are very
short everyone can verify them in a
constant number of queries and so on
an important application of pcps is in
the field of harness of approximation
pcps have been shown to be equivalent to
many fundamental results in this field
but it would be interesting to know
whether the slider notion of a pca can
still help us prove interesting results
and harness of approximation
um in our paper we actually show that
this is the case
we use pcas
for a proof sketch for
in reproving known harness approximation
results
specifically we use constant query
publicly verifiable pcas to show that
search maxsat is hard to approximate
now an actual question is whether we can
use pcas to show
new harness of approximation results for
which pcbs wouldn't suffice so for
example can we use this very short
notion of a succinct pca to show a new
harness of approximation results
we leave this open question for future
work
so let's move on to the second point on
our agenda on instance compression
instance compression defined by hannik
and all back in 2010 is the following
notion
say we have
a long instance x with a short witness w
once again think of sat
with very short assignments
and so an instance compression scheme is
a poly time computable function f which
maps the instance x into a shorter
instance x prime it compresses the
instance x into x prime where the length
of x prime is polynomial in the length
of w
second requirement for instance
compression is that it actually
preserves correctness so not only did we
compress x into something that is
comparable to the length of the witness
w and we also maintain that there exists
a witness w prime for x prime if and
only if there exists a witness w for x
so instance compression allows us to
shrink instances down to winston to
witness length while maintaining a
notion of correctness
an interesting application of instance
compression again provided by harmonic
no is or instance compression in which
the setting is slightly different
instead of having one long long instance
say we have k mini instances x1 to xk
and in this case an orients compression
function as a polytime computable
function f
which maps these k instances into a
single instance x prime
such as the following holes
first of all the length of x prime is
polynomial and the maximal length of x i
but also poly logarithmic and the length
of k
meaning that you can freely increase the
number of instances k without having a
drastic effect on the length of x prime
basically we compress k mini instances
and an unbounded number of instances
down to a single instance without having
much of an impact on its length
and second of all um x prime is true if
and only if there exists an index i such
that x i is true and this is why it's
called or instance compression
um and here's a visual example for this
fact and say we have instances x 1 to x
k all green all true
we map them using this function f into x
prime which is also true hence also
green
um if only one of these instances is
true maps
f still maps it into a true instance so
only one green on the left one green on
the right
and lastly if all of these are false all
of them are red we map them into a
single instance x prime which is again
going to be false
there are many more applications of
instance compression provided by hanik
and all
the first and most natural application
is storage say you have a bunch of
instances which are
very long and you want to solve them but
you're too lazy to solve them now what
you might want to do is apply some
instance compression function and make
them shorter and store them until you're
ready to solve them later
um
second of all we have kernelization
which is basically another way of saying
pre-processing
um in kernelization you have an instance
you can either decide using a very long
algorithm a or you can shrink it down
something that is comparable to its
witness much much shorter potentially
and apply some other algorithm a prime
which is going to run in less time
because its input is smaller
and lastly we have cryptography
how only can all show that assuming
instance compression for sat exists
they can solve many interesting open
problems in cryptography
so as we can see incest compression has
many natural applications
and the uh interesting question in this
context is whether instance compression
for sat even exists
um
and unfortunately for now synthetic once
again answer this question in the
negative 2011. um in the same paper as
before they showed that
assuming the polynomial hierarchy
doesn't collapse and there cannot be
instance compression for set
which is unfortunate but maybe we could
get something that is very very close
next to this compression um
by using cryptography
and here we have the notion of
computational instance compression which
we define
which is the following
say you have an instance x and a witness
w
um again the witness is much shorter um
and it's a computational instance
compression function or cac is a
polytime computable function f
which maps the instance x into another
instance x prime
which again x prime is going to be
comparable to the length of w
such that first of all if x is true then
x prime is true
just like we've had before and second of
all if x is false then it is intractable
to find a witness w prime for x prime
um
note that it says intractable not
impossible there might exist a witness w
prime for x prime even for false x's we
only require that finding one such
witness w prime is intractable
and lastly
we also require that there be a polytemp
computable function g
which allows you to map a witness w for
x into a witness w prime for x prime
and this basically allows you to
while shrinking x down to x prime prove
that you know a witness w
um for x by revealing the witness w
prime for x prime
so in this sense computational instance
compression does allow you to
shrink long instances into short ones
while maintaining a computational notion
of soundness
uh we show in theorem two that assuming
the same crypto as before we can get
computational instance compression or
cacs for
many in natural np relations so assume
once again sub-exponential lwe
then
we show that for every bounded depth and
p-relation there exists a c-a-c to set
so once again we allow
cacs for a very large subset of np and
note that the choice of target language
being set is arbitrary you can replace
it with your favorite
natural
np relation and it will actually work
so the proof of this theorem relies
heavily on theorem one
um on the pca result and actually
follows the template shown by
fornosantonum for showing that succinct
pcps imply instance compression we show
that succinct pcas imply computational
instance compression
so here's here's an interesting
application of cics that we call or cacs
just like or instance compression before
it allows us to shrink k instances x1 to
xk into a single instance x prime and
allows us to transform any of their
witnesses wi into a witness w prime for
x prime using this function g
once again if only one of these
instances is true you can transform its
witness and w2 into a witness w prime
and lastly if all of these instances are
false and the output instance x prime
might be true but is but it is
intractable to find a witness w prime
for x prime even though one such witness
might exist
great so let's move on to the last part
of our agenda the technical overview
so as a reminder theorem 1 states the
following assume subexponential lwe then
for every bounded depth and p relation
there exists publicly verifiable
constant query succinct pcas
we show this
by using succinct non-interactive
arguments or snargs which are a proof
system for p
we actually used the star construction
of jkkz from 2020 because it has a nice
holographic property which we'll discuss
in just a second
but we should know that there is also a
competing star construction by cjj from
2021
um which is not clear if it has the
holographic property but
if it can be shown to be holographic we
can actually use it in our construction
and to improve it in two ways
first of all we could eliminate the
sub-exponential lwe requirement we will
only need
an
lwe which is a lighter assumption and
therefore better
and second of all
if we could use cjj we can also get
pcas for all of np and not just a large
subset of np
np relations which would be better
but for now we use jkkz as we'll see in
just a second so let's begin
so what are snargs
snarks are a proof system for p so we
have a language on p and once again we
have a common random string a crs um and
in the setting uh we have a verifier who
again wants to know whether x belongs in
a language l
but this verifier isn't quite as lazy
he's uh no longer a sloth he's willing
to read the entire proof sent by the
prover as long as it's short succinct in
this case
so what the proverb does is he computes
a snark proof pi
um
and he sends pi over to the verifier
where the length of pi is poly
logarithmic in the length of x therefore
succinct
and the verifier reads the entirety of
the proof by entirety of x and the crs
and then decides whether to accept
reject
so jkkc
showed that assuming subexponential lwe
there exists publicly verifiable snarks
for of nc which we're going to be using
in the following way
uh here's our first attempt for the pca
construction using the snarg
we're going to have the prover basically
compute
a snark proof for the fact that x and w
belong in the
um
language rl
as a reminder rl is a language in p
and therefore has a snog um
which means that the prover can compute
that x and w are correct longer than
language
but since the verifier doesn't is lazy
in the setting and doesn't want to read
all of pi 1 the prover will also attach
a proof pi 2
for the fact that
had the verifier read of x w and pi 1 it
would have accepted
meaning that pi 2 proves that the snarg
verifier accepts x w and pi 1.
and the prover basically what he does is
he sends a uh
proof pi or an oracle to the proof pie
which contains w the witness pi 1 the
snark proof and pi 2
the proof showing that had the verify
read the snare it would have accepted
the verifier will then query this and
decide whether to accept or reject and
on the surface this seems to be
working but the there is a problem with
the proof length that we'll as we'll
discuss in just a second
so the proof length in the setting is at
least
the length of the proof pi 2 right
because pi contains pi 2
but the length of pi 2 is proportional
to the snark verifier runtime because pi
2 proves that the snark verifier
accepted
um
but the snark verifier has to read all
of its input text because it is a
regular computational machine um
[Music]
so therefore the length of pi 2 is at
least the length of x which means that
the length of pi
isn't polygraphically dependent on x it
is polynomially dependent on x which is
bad and not succinct as we'd like
uh so we're sad for now
and in order to solve this problem we
actually need a snog verifier for the
relation rl which is sublinear in the
length of x the explicit input
so
the idea here in order to get the
sublinear snark verifier is to use the
holographic property of the construction
of jkkz and what this means is the
following
the snark verifier of jkkz when it
receives the proof pi from the approver
what it basically does is that it looks
at an oracle of x hat we assume they
receive this kind of oracle x hat and
encoding of x
and using this oracle it only has to run
in sublinear time
specifically what it does is it only
needs to read the
encoding of x and indices j1 to jq
and what's it's read this oracle these
indices it can decide to accept or
reject
um
now this
composing a proof over this computation
and won't make it succinct
because at the very least you need to
describe the oracle
which means that the length of pi2 will
once again depend polynomially on the
length of x so instead what we do is we
use cryptography to compress
uh and this oracle to x hat
specifically in our sublinear snarg
verifier construction
we replace x hat with a commitment
to
this oracle x hat so we assume that the
snark verifier receives in advance
um a commitment to the oracle that it
wants to read
so maybe it pre-processed pre-processed
it or maybe someone else gave it the
commitment
and what it does
uh
is instead of reading the oracle indices
j1 to jq the prover sends the value of
this oracle at these indices using an
opening to this commitment
so
basically replace the oracle with a
cryptographic commitment and an opening
and the prover knows which values to
open because the snark verifier is
publicly verifiable
so now we can use the sublinear snark
verifier construction in the following
way
and
once again we have both of these parties
so what the verifier does in this case
even though it's lazy it computes
x hat the encoding of x and also
computes the commitment and which will
later be used by the snark verifier
um the prover computes pi 1 a snark
proof for the fact that x and w belong
in the language rl
it then computes the opening in the
values the indices that the
snark verifier would like to read of x
hat
again it knows these values because the
snark verifier is publicly verifiable
and lastly it computes a proof for the
fact that had the sublinear snag
verifier read um
all of w pi one open and then made the
quiz to
x hat it would have accepted so this is
the proof pi 2 proving that the snark
verify sonographer accepts
and the pca proof contains all these
values it contains a w pi one the snark
proof the opening to the commitment and
the proof that the snark verifier
accepts
um
the pca verifier simulates the snarg and
performs the queries over the uh proof
type ii and the to accept or eject
and this actually does provide for a
sound and a succinct pca construction as
we'd like thus completing the proof of
theorem 1.
so in conclusion and in this talk we
showed a couple of things
uh we assumed standard crypto and we
showed it for a very large subset of np
relations
and holds that
first of all there is exists a succinct
publicly verifiable constant query pcas
which can be used to show
some notions of hardness of
approximation
and second of all we show that there
exists computational instance
compression schemes and which can be
used for example
when building or computational instance
compression schemes
so thank you for listening and i hope
you enjoyed the talk